[Music]
rope chandelier as an artwork
it is not your
what you will imagine it to be as a
chandelier
the design singapore have given us like
a free birth to interpret this we
explain to them what the whole concept
idea you know that we need all this free
play i really want to do things a little
bit more spontaneous and organic
[Music]
as we are pushing moving this around we
just have to
visualize how it will react with the
rope eventually
it's fluid so end of the day
it should work out it will work out
[Music]
it is good to have timo and praise on
board you know to be able to do it we
want some chaos to it you know i think
the kills help sort of
create a sense of
juxtaposition of space
autistis himself he has an idea of how
this whole process and how this
installation for for me is i'm trying to
make sense out of this chaos
knowing that you may fail but not being
afraid that you will feel
i will do all i can to make sure it
what works
you feel
then it's okay
[Music]
very often in our work we seek to have
this emotional connection in the art
itself
i'm trying to send out a statement that
you have to recognize that in design you
need expression
that you need to give freedom
inspiration can come from just the
process of doing things
[Music]
i think that people come in experience
it and they can have their own
interpretation of what this is
i think everyone is born artistic and
everyone is born with a creative mind
whatever that comes whatever they see
will be what they take away
hopefully there's inspiration for some
people who encounter it maybe you give
design singapore to be able to even do
more abstract
design
projects
someone told me that they were expecting
rope and the grandiose
crystals and all that but breaking that
illusion i'm i'm very happy with that i
think we have achieved it to quite quite
a big degree
[Music]
you